welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
and marvel's hawkeye just gave us our
strongest evidence yet that joining the
mcu is one of the biggest marvel
villains wilson fisk kingpin a rumored
return by vincent d'onofrio from the
netflix daredevil now running a criminal
operation less afraid to fat shame him
just don't do it in front of vanessa
embarrassed me in front of her
now there's actually quite a bit of
evidence that sets up wilson fisk's new
existence in hawkeye and in the broader
mcu but even more exciting than just him
coming back at all is what his presence
means to the mcu storylines coming up
and how he could be the missing link to
the way the post in game marvel world
continues to try to blow itself up so
let's break down the evidence and stare
into the white cracked paint on the wall
to find some insight from the outset
hawkeye pitched itself as very much the
kind of series that wilson fisk could
plow into the way loki seemed to be the
kind of show that kang might show up in
in the marvel comics kingpin is known as
the oversized villain to spider-man who
oversees much of new york's organized
crime looming above the law as a goliath
of real estate and then really any
friendly neighborhood vigilante in the
city runs afoul of fisk sooner or later
daredevil punisher and in the 2012
fraction aha comics hawkeye and kate
bishop in which they face the tracksuit
gang who report to kingpin this disney
plus hawkeye series seems to be adapting
that storyline more closely than any
other marvel disney plus series yet has
stuck to their source material the show
also introduces echo maya lopez who in
the comics becomes kingpin's adopted
daughter after her father's death which
really goes pretty much the same way in
hawkeye episode 3 down to a mysterious
uncle mentor figure to maya who is now
maya's boss this uncle wears a tailored
suit with cufflinks and walks with heavy
footsteps and laughs in a way that
sounds a lot like vince donafrio's laugh
uncle will take you home after class
i'll see you tonight
[Music]
did you finally get something to eat
we we wrapped okay
but the cuff links appear to be the
telltale clue because as we saw in
netflix daredevil wilson fisk is
obsessed with cufflinks he's got a whole
drawer full of them with these cufflinks
it's hard to tell what the design is
because from this angle all we really
see is the stopper clip that pokes
through the inside of the cuff whatever
the flashy design is would show up on
the other side the outside of the wrist
but back in episode one the hotel where
kate attends eleanor's event is the
real-life lot new york palace hotel a
location that in daredevil season 3 was
used as the presidential hotel that
wilson fisk bought and spent the
duration of his house arrest in this
location in hawkeye armand accused
eleanor of building her empire
deceptively on the back of an
association with a powerful shady third
party one that he could threaten with
powerful friends of his own this is also
the location of the auction an auction
that in the comics kingpin is in
attendance but this auction mentions one
specific head of organized crime that
the ronin nearly annihilated the power
and status of and then in episode three
clint references this top boss again
they started small for group there's the
guy at the top
he'll do anything to grow the operation
i thought maya was the boss
now there's someone above maya someone
you don't want to mess with episode 3
also shows us a tracksuit mafia front
business called fat man auto repairs the
track suits have a track record of shell
companies that reference themselves this
does sound like a name that they might
use to pay respect to the big guy really
all of this evidence is on top of
various rumors that kingpin would appear
in the series fueled largely by vincent
d'onofrio's own curious social media
activity around the hawkeye trailer
releases the week before the premiere he
tweeted with a hawkeye promo video this
is going to be fun and this was after
numerous past instances where followers
jumped on him for hawkeye related
postings after which he would then try
to cover his tracks so he knew what he
was doing here d'onofrio also responded
to a rumored visualization of his wilson
fisk as a larger bulkier framed kingpin
the way the character is often shown in
the comics to which he said it's a
really bad job from someone trying to
make it look like me this guy in the pic
is more handsome i think you know
sometimes these details are just so
wonderful to find it's almost like they
were custom designed for us it's like
unwrapping a gift something that was
perfectly intended just for you well
what if the one thing you spend most of
the time in your life using was
perfectly crafted for you well thanks to
helix you can get the mattress intended
for you healing sleep makes premium
mattresses and bedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped right to your
door helix is a sleep quiz that matches
your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you i took the quiz and got matched with
the dusk luxe helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool i've had
it for over a year and i love it it
totally delivers on all of the great
features helix delivers your mattress
right to your door for free it comes
rolled up in a surprisingly small box
and is super easy to set up yourself
helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
can get more than three months to make
sure that you love it and if you don't
love it they will pick it up for you and
you will get a full refund i love my
helix and i think you would too so if
you're looking for a new bed check out
helix you can check out the link below
or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress ultimately it seems like
the watch from avengers compound the
item at auction that the tracksuits were
sent to retrieve is going to be the key
confirming that uncle truly is d'onofrio
wilson fisk and more importantly what
uncle's plans are that clint barton and
kate bishop are about to interfere with
clint actually alludes to that loose
threat of the watch to kate in episode
three do you think that the tracksuits
were after anything else at that auction
it's pretty upsetting to think there
might be stuff in the avengers compound
floating around out there this
establishes the bigger avengers level
threat for the remaining episodes of
this season to be weaponry and other
advanced tech stolen from the wreckage
of avengers compound after end game
which endgame did clue us into by having
a helicopter in the background took
something away from that wreckage and
these goodies now in the hands of the
worst people in the world in other words
loose boobs something i get a case of
when i don't share enough of my pizza
with the dog
this is also the threat posed at the end
of the falcon the winter soldier if you
remember when the power broker sharon
carter who hired a chemist to
manufacture new super soldier serum in
magipore scored a pardon from the us
government after her post-award legal
troubles and couldn't even wait to get
back to her hotel to start making evil
plans start lining up our buyers
super soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access to
government secrets prototype weapons you
name it
should be something for everyone this
seemed to be setting up the armor wars
series on disney plus which is going to
feature roadie dealing with iron man
weaponry getting into the wrong hands
one of carter's buyers in that moment
may very well have been uncle whether or
not he's confirmed to be wilson fisk
because i pointed out a few times how
that tracksuit lieutenant ivan seems to
be more physically enhanced than normal
he deflects the usb arrow kate fired at
him on the bridge and he punches out a
car window with his bare fist now while
more aggro strength than superpowers it
is the kind of boost that john walker
seemed to get when he took that serum
it's also interesting how much this
hawkeye series is shouting out ant-man
from ant-man's random inclusion in
rogerson musical to the pymtech arrow
that hawkeye used on the bridge this
tells us that ever since in game clint
has been apparently supplied at least in
part by hank pym this partnership may
inform clint's new concern about the
tech being in wrong hands which is
always a major concern of hanks you sent
my suit to the mail and coming out of
that movie ant-man the wasp we never got
an answer as to who sonny burch's
mysterious buyer was who was super eager
to get his hands on pym tech that buyer
could be uncle and uncle could be wilson
fisk kingpin repeat customer of the
power broker and titan of crime eager to
gobble up all things stamped with the
name stark and pym and with a guy that
big you know there's going to be some
big old loose boobs to support this
channel check out one of our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thank
you for watching bye
[Music]
you